when I went to UCR so there was um two
kids one guy there's there's two Andy's
that were so [ __ ] weird
there was Korean Andy and then there was
[ __ ] Chinese Andy right so don't name
your kid Andy did not aim their kid Andy
if you're an Andy out there mm-hmm but
uh Andy this is his name was spelt and
died right a Andy ie I kid you not that
was how you spelled his [ __ ] and the
only way that I could differentiate them
was how it's call him and I and and I
would specifically do that he hated that
[ __ ] but he used to [ __ ] annoy me
because he was like one of those dudes
like and I yeah let me tell you how
[ __ ] phony this guy is right number
one when I came to that school I never
acted like I was a thug right but I
guess like when they when people hear
you speak they they kind of assume what
you are yeah but mind you like if you
just looked at me right you [ __ ] do
we need glasses and you know that you
would never think but this guy every
time he sounds like that's like when
people don't really have any black
friends and then they finally hang out
around black people they start they try
to go extra-urban and [ __ ] yo yo yo I'm
like it's so crazy man so the funny
thing about college is what you can do
in college in which you'll find out if
you're not in college it you will always
find these people and you'll sniff them
out they'll they when they go to a
university they go okay nobody knows me
here I'm gonna create my own identity
yeah and this is what this guy was
trying to do yeah they try to start
fresh yeah so this [ __ ] right he
was by definition and I don't know talk
about a geek in terms of like what he
likes I'm talking about geek as and he
is so cringy he was so [ __ ] cringy
dude he showed up I kid you not when I
first met him he is like he looked up a
video about how to walk like a thug and
if you try to imitate it you know I mean
it looked like he had a broken leg I
cannot make this [ __ ] up
so he's walking around like you know
just kind of like yo yo yo yo and then
he wore this black wife beater oh my god
I like these baggy pants which at the
time weren't even in yes I'm like you
know what the [ __ ] is this fool doing
doing them and he's like stars like yeah
man yeah what's up man yeah I got some
homies does like yeah I'm hard a bah
blah blah like Edward I'm sitting there
just just dying on the inside like what
is this guy [ __ ] during college you
fool he's
he's in a university that's the whole
point of this [ __ ] so my last straw was
this so there was this dude and call his
name was James and this guy was a klepto
he he likes stealing love stealing and
mind you he's a rich kid like it's from
he's from from Diamond Bar he lives in
the country that [ __ ] secluded like I
did area that's where like snoop lives
and [ __ ] yeah guys mad rich but he's a
klepto loves to steal we used to go to a
Food For Less to get all of our [ __ ]
yeah I'm sama he's so good at stealing
that I didn't know how to steal [ __ ]
until I saw him I've never really stolen
stuff but he would steal stuff so well
because he would take things as if it
was already his yeah that's what it was
you gotta steal yeah it just doesn't
look like he's stealing it yeah you
can't be like exact he just walks in
yeah and so for him
what he would do is he would steal his
hungry man dinners and so we will put
that in our dorm fridges right [ __ ] like
he's poor he's rich though I'm dying
he's bawling
it's like he's a lad and he needs a
Apple and [ __ ] is he stealing food no
I'm talking about he's so [ __ ] rich
when we went to his place out in Diamond
Bar yeah like his place looks like a
[ __ ] castle he had a tennis court in
the back and I think like it looked like
a helicopter landing pad I think I'm
exaggerating it right now but that's
what it looked like to me and back in
the day he had like a 50-inch plasma TV
and that [ __ ] was like 10 grand wow this
is like in 2005 yeah so he had that on
as well that's how ball it is and mind
you he's 18 at this point but anyways
he's stealing some [ __ ] right he stole
for the thrill yeah so just the hungry
man dinners stole it and so when we went
back to the dorm were like yo we got to
put this in all everybody's fridges just
giving it to everybody in the dorm yeah
we'll just put it in their fridges and
they'll be cool with the hair just take
it anyway that's free so this dude Andy
comes up right I [ __ ] [ __ ] you not
walks up to egos a so this this dude his
name is Rishi he goes hey Rishi can I
talk to you
it goes Rishi yo man y'all have been
into some [ __ ] so uh I can't have these
hungry man dinners in my fridge cuz you
know because the Popo might come after
crazy just talking about this I
completely forgot about this guy he goes
yo
so I did you take the hungry man dinners
out
I might get into some [ __ ] you know the
COS be looking after me they got my
phone tapped oh my god I'm not even
[ __ ] [ __ ] you dude and I got so
full under surveillance and the hungry
man dinners might put him in a jail good
I got so [ __ ] mad like I had at that
best point oh look I should I looked at
this dude and I said dude what the [ __ ]
are you talking about man well it is the
cops gonna [ __ ] fly through the
[ __ ] window and scream where's the
hungry man dinners nobody gives a [ __ ]
dude I was so mad it's because he's such
a thug yeah tell that he feels guilty
he's afraid yep he doesn't want to be
caught with stolen goods so I'm hungry
man dinners I know and like sorry you
know how innocent he is dude it made me
cry me was getting anxiety like oh my
god not the Salisbury steak at that
point I just took my [ __ ] with the guy
cuz he irritated me so much it was like
dude this is not working for you just be
yourself so I would have kept it going
that's hilarious ha I just like that was
the last straw under investigation from
what prop man I got my phone tapped man
[ __ ] I'm a secret agent you know like I
got oh I got this bubblegum thing I'm
got going on you know it's you know I
got a I've been stealing winter fresh
you guys are seeing like when I write a
lot of these scripts mm-hmm and you see
these weird characters that pop up is
literally these type of human beings
that I meet I belong funnier than the
truth if there's nothing funnier like it
almost sounds so made-up but I can't
even make [ __ ] up like this so there's
even the Kim jong-il character if you
guys remember that kid that is based off
of a real human being that I've met
number one is based off my uncle who's a
weirdo yeah and number two is also the
other Andy in the college dorm that I
met yeah and that's who I based these
characters off of yeah but these people
nobody [ __ ] with them because they just
couldn't be themselves right they just
really cut it and some people - they're
so good at hiding it that a lot of
people buy into it yeah there's another
I mean I've been fooled many times
yeah it's likable people yeah I mean
sometimes things are too perfect but you
just can't accept that something might
be wrong with this dude
because you like being around them and
hanging out like even in relationships
right I mean guys and girls get
manipulated all the time yeah from like
it's like it's like it's like nice guys
like sometimes there's genuine nice guys
but there's like those weird ones that
are like they actually want to bone the
crap out of this girl yeah but then
they're pretending to be the friend
the Churchill buddy yeah but they're not
honest with their feelings and [ __ ] and
then but they don't want to let go of
that like closeness with them yeah yeah
yeah well they you know guys also do
that just because they're afraid of
rejection like they they could always
just say oh I was just trying to be your
friend yeah but that's manipulation yeah
for sure not it's not and then they
don't know that they're doing it but I
think a lot of these guys too they don't
know that
how fraudulent they are yeah I think
they just really want to be something so
I hate that term like fake it till you
make it cuz a lot of people misinterpret
what that means oh that's right like
they're gonna dress the part they're
gonna act apart cuz they want to be
accepted as this image of who they want
to be it's pretty complex if you think
about it yeah it's like it's like a
person who is like let's say they have
low confidence right but they like I'm
in college now I'm gonna start fresh
like I used to be bullied all the time
in high school but now I'm gonna change
things so now I'm gonna be like super
confident and I'm gonna be different and
that's cool and all but there's a fine
line between like challenging yourself
and being a fraud and I think the people
that don't understand the difference
they become frauds because they do
shortcuts mmm and like you know for that
kid and died you know if you're
listening to this dude you were [ __ ]
weird what you could have done
conversely was not pretend to be a thug
you had just been confident in who you
are the dweeb and he has a really smart
guy yeah you know you could have just
been confident in that human being and
mind you in our dorm there were it's
there was a lot of like dweeby dudes but
they were so dope because they just were
open about who you were and that was
that was the cool part was their
confidence and that was the difference
man I got home he hit me up recently his
name is Tony my girlfriend Gardena just
like you but he was like he was like a
magnet school student but and he never
pretended like to be a feller a but he
was such to me he was such a cool dude
just because I could connect with him so
well because he was always on
with themselves now mind you he was also
weird but a weird type of way that I
like yeah so we were door mates coming
to the bathroom he goes hey Davey can
you check out my pee real quick